The Marxists,
we're happy that religion had collapsed
because they thought that that would
eliminate an entire strata of oppression.
And you can see that it's
not like the Catholic church,
for example,
was free of corruption.
You know,
it was in many ways it corrupt enterprise
and you could read it as solely a
corrupt enterprise.
And you know,
to hell with it,
it's good that it's gone.
And,
uh,
you know,
the Friday and it's basically
thought the same way.
And so did most intellectuals,
Freud thought that
religion was nothing than,
uh,
than a childish delusion that people
identified with because
they were afraid of dying.
It was a,
you know,
it was a defense against death,
anxiety.
Look,
the Marxist argument and the,
and the Friday and argument,
those are bloody powerful arguments,
you know,
cause you can see it.
You do.
People use the religious belief
as a defense against things.
They're too terrified to confront.
Well,
obviously,
you know,
there's the Churchill press,
people did it.
Oh,
press people,
get it.
Engage in,
you know,
conspiracies with people
in power across centuries.
It's like,
obviously,
you know,
the question is,
well,
what do you make of that?
Well,
partly you make of it that all
sorts of structures do that.
It's like structures do that and you know,
you can't just damn one structure
and thanked the others are going to,
you know,
it's like the right wingers,
they're always owned about big government,
how terrible that isn't.
Left wingers are always on about
how big corporations are terrible.
It's like,
well,
Bang is terrible.
It doesn't matter if it's government or
corporations because things tend to tilt
towards corruption across time and
then that has to be taken into account.
But anyway,
so the Friday ends and the
intellectuals and the Marxists,
we're all pretty happy when the religious
dream started to come apart and they
believe that the new edifice is that
they were going to construct fascist and
communist would be so much better
than what they replaced that,
you know,
everybody would be
drowning in utopia and uh,
it's kind of too bad that
isn't how it turned out,
but it's certainly not how it turned out.
How it turned out was,
hmm.
Sometimes when you tear something down,
even if you think it's terrible,
you end up constructing something on its
ruins that makes the previous terrible
look like the work of rank amateurs.
And that's certainly what
happened in the 20th century.
I mean,
no matter what you say about the
Catholic Church and its basic barbarism,
especially when you know they were
involved in the witch hunt in the middle
ages,
it's like those guys,
they were amateurs compared to
the fascists and the communists.
You know,
they were counting their victims
in the tens of thousands,
not the hundreds of millions.